gilbert casasus bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors cet accord
durement acquis pour les vingt-sept et
finalement le parlement s'y opposent
concrètement à quelle marge de manoeuvre
ont-ils je pense que la marge de
manoeuvre du parlement européen est une
manoeuvre marge manoeuvre d'abord
politique pour montrer son existence
vis-à-vis de la commission et vis-à-vis
du conseil des ministres c'est à dire
des paiements c'est à dire qu'ils
veulent faire pression
sachant que le parlement européen a
essayé de plus en plus d'être un acteur
déterminant dans le cadre de la prise de
décision de l'union européenne
il y a des terres il y a aussi des
reproches justifier que le parlement
européen peut avoir à l'encontre ou peux
t'exprimer avoir a lentement de l'accord
cela concerne notamment des coupes
budgétaires
et je parle là plutôt des coupes
budgétaires dans le cadre des mesures
pour l'environnement et aussi le non
respect d'après beaucoup de
parlementaires européens de la règle du
droit sachant qu organe et la pologne
donc la hongrie et la pologne ont obtenu
une formulation assez vague sur la
question du respect de l'état de droit
dans le cas de l'union européenne alors
que va-t-il concrètement se passer c'est
le parlement européen n'approuve pas cet
accord non je ne pense pas qu'il ne peut
pas le prouver c'est à dire que tout
simplement c'est d'une pression
politique et exercer il ya encore
quelques semaines de temps c'est à dire
que le parlement repères veut se
profiler par rapport au conseil des
ministres par rapport aux états membres
ils vont essayer certainement de mener
ou de guerre qui justifie d'ailleurs
démocratiquement mais ce sont des
responsables les dents le parlement
européen est quand même majorité
d'européens
ils savent très bien qu'ils ne vont pas
mettre en cause un accord qui a été
acquis après de très longues et dures
négociations et de remettre tout en
cause parce que là c'est même eux qui me
ne règle politique un peu suicidaire car
aujourd'hui on a bien vu ce qui s'est
passé à bruxelles il ya les pro
européens et ceux qui le seront un peu
moi et quand vous êtes pro européen
vous ne jouez pas la politique du pire
par rapport aux anti européen donc je
considère qu'il y à une menace que cette
menace légitime à certains égards mais
néanmoins je suis relativement optimiste
qu'il n'y ait pas de bébé tour alors ce
qui peut se passer
c'est qu'il y a on voit qu'on ne vote
pas le budget européen et qu'on joue sur
un nouveau vote convient sur 10 des
dépenses échelonner ses ennemis dans
l'intérêt de l'union européenne ni dans
l'intérêt du parlement européen il faut
savoir raison garder en la matière si on
va dans les détails de cette menace le
parlement parle d'améliorations
qu'est-ce que parlement demande
exactement à travers ces améliorations
dans cet accord des 27 répondeur pas
plus d'europe et pas plus de respect des
principes européens
c'est ça qui est important c'est à dire
qu'ils ont majorité d'entre eux y de
témoin président italien du parlement
européen un social-démocrate totalement
responsable c'est très bien qu'il y à
des défaillances dans cet accord qu'il
ya des points sur lesquels on aurait pu
obtenir un autre résultat je reviens ce
que je disais en matière
environnementale en matière ou si du
respect de la règle de droit
en fait je pense que le parlement
européen et c'est son rôle et c'est
démocratique c'est justifié veut 10 ont
montré sa force par rapport au pouvoir
exécutif mais aussi appuyer là où ça
fait un peu mal sachant qu'à mon avis et
je ne peux que me répéter il n'y auront
pas jusqu'au bout de leur logique qu'à
mettre en cause un accord si
difficilement conclu ce serait
véritablement mener une politique
totalement suicidaire
il ya un autre point abordé également
par le parlement européen se tenir la
promesse des taxes pour rembourser y at
il une inquiétude à avoir sur ce plan de
relance parce que cet argent il va
falloir le rembourser c'est aussi sur
cinq le parlement
on tient tête à la commission alors là
il faut quand même savoir que on a
franchi un nouveau pas un pas important
vers la fédéralisation de dépenses et le
remboursement des subventions est prévu
dans un laps de temps de 30 ans voire
plus
donnant du temps au temps ce n'est pas
là-dessus qu'on va quand même remettre
en cause un accord qui est là pour
donner une impulsion nouvelle à
l'économie européenne et pour sauver des
millions d'emplois si le parlement
européen veut jouer être plus royaliste
que le roi
c'est son droit le plus strict mais cela
se termine toujours très bas dans
l'histoire
la position de la france vis-à-vis de
cette menace qu'elles étaient les commet
emmanuel macron angela merkel peuvent
ils réagir vis-à-vis de cette possible
menace avec la raison de ce qu'ils ont
mené une politique jusqu'à présent
relativement raisonnable il faut quand
même souligner le changement de
paradigme allemand il faut saluer le
courage des madame merkel qui a pris ses
distances depuis donc été relativement
proches je pense que tu aimeras
l'autriche qui est maintenant fait
partie des frigos ou dit hamada selon
l'expression que l'on emploie et la
pression est là je crois qu'elle sera
très plein grande de macron sur le
groupe libéral de mme merkel sur le pps
d'arthur lebouc chrétiens démocrates
mais aussi de certains
sociaux-démocrates et je pense boucler
zig d'anti celui de sur le couple social
démocrate qui vivaient mes
social-démocrate disons c'est ensemble
de propre et un chrétiens démocrates
libéraux et sociaux-démocrates feront
certainement fera certainement pencher
la balance dans le sens d'une certaine
raison et
voyez le cas incroyable de voir que ces
parties là qui sont les parkings
fondamentaux de l'europe faire alliance
avec des eurosceptiques ou des
adversaires et grelots type de l'europe
ça serait véritablement inimaginable je
pense que c'est un coup de poker
justifier ce n'est pas un coup de bluff
c'est un coup de poker mais c'est aussi
faire pression et il y a des
revendications qui sont justifiées
notamment sur les questions de droits
sur les questions d'écologie et sur le
fait que peut-être qu'on est mécontent
de telle et telle répartition du budget
mais attention
souvenons nous du montant qui est dans
qu'il était de question du budget
européen avant la crise et regardons
maintenant le bon temps une différence
et non au profit du budget européen
donc on a beaucoup plus réussi à
atteindre que ce qu'on imaginait il ya
encore quelques mois
donc là ou si la région devrait
l'emporter merci beaucoup gilbert
casadesus d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en direct sur rt franc je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'études européennes à l'université
bilingue à de fribourg